وإلى meme ، لقد كنت صديقًا لي
لفترة طويلة قبل أن أفعل هذا
الشيء الرئاسي ، ونشعر
براحة شديدة مع بعضنا البعض
ويجب أن أقول إن الاستثمارات التي
تقوم بها في الولايات المتحدة هي واحدة من
أكبر الاستثمارات في  العالم
ولكن الاستثمارات التي تقوم بها
موضع تقدير كبير ، فأنا أعلم الطائرات
التي تشتريها وجميع الأشياء الأخرى
التي تستثمر فيها وأراها بشكل
مختلف وأرى أنها وظائف لأنها
بالنسبة لي وظائف واليوم نضع
سجل للوظائف التي نضعها
على أساس يومي تقريبًا ، وصلنا إلى ما يقرب من
مائة وستين مليون وظيفة
وهذه إحصائية
واضحة جدًا وبالتالي هناك المزيد من الأشخاص الذين
يعملون إذا كنت تعتقد أن المزيد من الأشخاص يعملون
في الولايات المتحدة  يشير اليوم أكثر من
أي يوم في تاريخنا ، إنه
رقم مهم للغاية وهو بسيط ، لكن
من المحتمل أن يكون جميلًا بقدر ما يمكننا أن نفعله
، يفهم كل شخص في الغرفة ذلك
جيدًا
ولكني أريد فقط أن أشكرك على أننا
سنلتقي غدًا وهذا سيحدث  سيكون اجتماعًا ممتعًا للغاية ،
ربما يمكننا أن نفعل
كل شيء الليلة ليس علينا أن نهتم به
غدًا ، سيكون على ما يرام
سنوفر بعض الوقت الجيد ، لكنني أتطلع
إلى ذلك ، فلدينا اجتماع كبير مع
ممثليكم ولدينا الكثير لنفعله
نتحدث عن العديد من الأشياء التي
سنتحدث عنها من الدفاع
إلى المشتريات والتجارة وأنا أعلم أن
كل شيء سيكون إيجابياً للغاية ،
لقد كنت حليفاً عظيماً وقد
ساعدتنا في تركيب عسكري رائع
ومطار عسكري
أمثال لم يرها الناس
منذ فترة طويلة وأنا أفهم أن
هناك ثمانية مليارات دولار أخرى مستثمرة ،
أشكر الله في الغالب أن أموالك وليست أموالنا
في الواقع ، بل إنها كانت كل
أموالهم ليست أموالنا وهذا أفضل ولكن
لديك  كنت رائعًا وكنت
صديقي العظيم وأنا أقدر ذلك
وأتطلع إلى
رؤيتك غدًا ، وسنعقد بعض المحادثات الجيدة جدًا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم جميعًا على تواجدكم هنا [تصفيق  هـ]